Welcome to problem set 1, we are going to be going over the running time today
and what it means for an algorithm to be efficient or slow or difficult.
So we're going to be going over few problems along those lines
so I will go ahead and just typewrite it.
So let's say we consider ourselves more practical engineers than theoretical scientist.
So we're somewhere over here maybe.
So we don't really want to look at algorithm code and try to figure out the running times
instead what we rather do is implement the algorithms and then measure them,
measure the running times of the algorithm for just some random instances let's say of various sizes
and see where things go.
So let's take a look at the three algorithms called alpha, beta, and gamma in this table.
And we're running them on different input sizes.
An input size of 100, 200, 300, and 400, and we're showing the running times.
Now, this is just for one run of each of these algorithms.
Let's say we're running each of these algorithms a million times on a random input of the given size
so running alpha a million times on an input size of 100
and different randomly generated inputs of size 100,
and it is taking an average of 25, and all these are in minutes.
And similarly for an input size of 200, we're running alpha a million times on random inputs of size 200,
and it's taking an average 317,000 minutes so you can see a growth somewhat quickly.
We can ask a number of questions about these three algorithms.
The first question I would like to ask is what is the running time for each algorithm,
alpha, beta, and gamma, based on the information in this table.
And you might be a little bit confused here because if alpha has linear running time
then it also has polynomial and exponential running time since those are worse than linear running time.
And similarly, if beta has polynomial running time then it's also exponential running time,
but it's not linear running time then.
Don't worry too much about that just give the lowest running time you can for each algorithm
and check which one applies for each of the algorithms.